علينا تحذير مشاهدينا من أن بعض
مقاطع الفيديو في هذا التقرير
سيجدونها مزعجة
[موسيقى]
كيون البالغ من العمر تسع سنوات أراد أن يكون
مخترعًا يستعرض قاربًا خشبيًا
صنعه لمسابقة لا نعرف
متى  تم تصوير مقطع فيديو ، ظهر
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بعد مقتل كيون الصغير
، كان واحدا من بين عدد من الأشخاص الذين
قُتلوا يوم الأربعاء فيما قالت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
إنه حادث إطلاق نار في
مدينة إيزي جنوب غرب البلاد حيث
اندلعت الاحتجاجات المناهضة للحكومة
منذ أيام.  تقول الحكومة الإيرانية إن كيون
كان في طريقه إلى المنزل مع والده عندما
أصيب بالرصاص
، وتقول الحكومة الإيرانية إن هذا كان
هجومًا إرهابيًا ، لكن نشطاء يقولون
إن كيان ضحية حملة النظام القاسية
على الاحتجاجات ، وهو واحد من بين أكثر من
40 طفلاً قُتلوا منذ سبتمبر / أيلول
وفقًا لمجموعات حقوقية.
كل يوم لأكثر من 60 يومًا حتى الآن
يدفن الإيرانيون ديونهم
أكثر من 300 شخص فقدوا في هذه المعركة من
أجل التغيير ، أصيب بوذا كرامي البالغ من العمر 30 عامًا
برصاصة في الرأس يوم الأربعاء.
للنشطاء هذا
الفيديو المزعج يلتقط لحظة اصطدامه برصاصة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دفن والدة المشيع لا
تحزن على طفلك ،
سننتقم له مع كل جنازة
يزداد غضبهم من الوحشية ويؤجج
عزمهم على المخاطرة بكل شيء  من أجل
تغيير النظام الذي يكافح النظام لاحتواء
الانتفاضة الشعبية ، يحكم الآن على
المتظاهرين بالإعدام ، وقد حُكم على العديد منهم
بالإعدام هذا الأسبوع فيما
وصفته جماعات حقوق الإنسان بأنها
محاكمات صورية ، وهي أحدث
محاولة للجمهورية القمعية لسحق السقوط المتزايد ، لكن
لا شيء يبدو كذلك.  وقف
إرادة الشعب
بدأ الشهر الثالث من الانتفاضة
بموجة جديدة من الإضرابات والاحتجاجات
تجتاح البلاد
[تصفيق
] الأصوات المتصاعدة من أجل الحرية
رافضة إسكاتها.